par présent à la chasse aux fausses
informations
[Musique]
et direction l'Iran pour ce numéro
d'info intox bonjour Anthony Saint-Léger
bonjour à Fred bonjour à tous le
mouvement de contestation à se poursuit
après la mort de Marsa mini et la
répression aussi des vidéos sensibles
au sociaux mais attention certaines sont
trompeuses effectivement on va se
content centrer sur une vidéo ce soir
une dizaine de secondes que l'on va
découvrir ensemble regarder une vidéo
assez impressionnante on y voit des
personnes qui en attaquent d'autres à
coups de feu d'artifice alors il y a du
son sur cette vidéo ça donne un côté
encore plus impressionnant que nous
disent les comptes qu'il a partagent et
bien pour celui-ci par exemple il s'agit
d'une attaque donc de la police des
mœurs dont on a beaucoup parlé
évidemment ces derniers jours à coup de
feu d'artifice une attaque aussi des
Gardiens de la Révolution islamique et
cette chaîne pro russe sur son compte
télégramme évoque elle aussi ses feux
d'artifice des jeux de des jets de
pierre et même vous le voyez des
cocktails Molotov en somme donc c'est
violent sont a priori liés aux
manifestants en cours en Iran mais si
cette vidéo est bien authentique en
chaîne elle n'a rien à voir avec l'Iran
Anthony effectivement on est dans un
exemple type d'un détournement de vidéo
on va regarder cela ensemble lorsque
l'on fait une recherche d'image inversée
pour connaître l'origine exacte de ces
images on s'aperçoit d'abord que la
vidéo virale a été tronquée elle est
plus courte donc que la vidéo d'origine
une vidéo plus longue apparaît par
exemple sur ce compte Twitter indonésien
vidéo plus longue vous le voyez je vous
disais tout à l'heure une dizaine de
secondes on est à 23 secondes ici plus
de
2.500000 vues et cette date 22 octobre
donc ce compte Twitter indonésien qui
mentionne un mot mangaraï et mangaraï et
bien c'est un quartier de Jakarta c'est
au sud précisément Jakarta la capitale
indonésienne ici le alors on va
justement vérifier cette hypothèse on se
rend sur Google en faisant une recherche
sur les actualités de Google avec ces
trois mots mangaraï kempang happy feu
d'artifice et manga rail et vous voyez
que les occurrences nous ramènent à des
articles de presse locaux qui se sont
fait écho d'affrontements qui ont eu
lieu donc précisément à mangaraï entre
des habitants de quartier mitoyens à
coup donc de feu d'artifice lyrics ont
eu lieu le 4 le 14 et le à 18 septembre
dernier et on retrouve d'ailleurs des
images de série X sur le compte
Instagram d'un média local Jakarta info
on va confirmer tout ça grâce à la
géolocalisation
en effet Google Street View l'outil va
nous permettre de géolocaliser à la fois
la photo virale et les photos
d'Instagram dont je vous parlais à
l'instant à mon garage regardez on va
prendre une capture d'écran de la photo
virale de tout à l'heure et regardez la
géolocalisation de manga rail plusieurs
indices visuels coïncides vous avez ici
le fameux pont que l'on retrouve sur
cette vidéo de moins bonne qualité
évidemment et puis ici aussi ce panneau
vous voyez il est bien mentionné Jakarta
et mangaray ici que l'on retrouve sur la
vidéo virale ici notons toutefois qui
n'a pas été possible de dater
précisément l'événement de la vidéo
virale mais quoi qu'il en soit vous
l'aurez compris rien à voir avec les
manifestations qui secouent l'Iran
actuellement une mise au point à présent
inconsciemment la vidéo virale d'une
iranienne qui refaisait son chignon
devenu un symbole des femmes qui
manifeste en Iran effectivement
impossible de passer à côté de ces
images dans cette qui réajuste son
chignon avant une manifestation relayée
depuis le 25 septembre par des comptes
et des médias internationaux dont France
24 qui affirmait qu'il s'agissait de A10
Najafi avant que cette femme soit tuée
elle est devenue un peu le deuxième
symbole après Marseille à midi de ce
mouvement de protestation qui secoue
l'Iran sauf que c'est faux je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi le 26 septembre une
femme contacte BBC Perse pour assurer
qu'elle est la femme de cette vidéo
qu'elle n'est donc par conséquent pas
décédé et qu'elle ne s'appelle pas à 10
Najafi ensuite le média en langue perce
Radio zamanais Contact lui la famille de
A10 Najafi qui explique effectivement
qu'elle a cru elle aussi que c'était
cette personne sur la vidéo qu'elle
s'est méprise du fait des similitudes
physiques entre les deux femmes mais
l'histoire de adis Najafi et bien vrai
puisqu'à 10 Najafi est une Iranienne de
22 ans qui a été tué par des balles de
chevrotines de dans le visage dans le
cou et dans la poitrine lors d'une
manifestation à kiraj le 21 septembre
dernier d'ailleurs sa sœur a publié sur
son compte Instagram à la fois son
certificat de décès et des photos de ces
funérailles Adas pardon A10 Najafi c'est
donc bien cette femme qui est morte lors
d'une manifestation mais ce n'est pas la
femme de cette vidéo comme il a pu être
affirmé c'est dernier jour merci Anthony
Saint Léger info intox c'est terminé
nous on se retrouve dans trois minutes
pour un nouveau journal